no one's ever come in a gun's ablaze
what like julie bowen nobody has ever
come in me this is like i was i was
doing like pump up laps in my house like
you got this you got this like a 14 year
old boy before
the big game
and i was so nervous because why it's us
no because i've listened to you way too
much i've listened to you and like i
said i feel like i've got the code and
so
although i am losing track of it i'm not
sure there is a code i honestly don't
think there is i think but um
not an intentional part anyway i don't
pay attention that much i know we all
know i zone out that is your enemy that
has always been your mo has you zoned
out sona why do you put up with this
that's a he puts up with a lot too but
are you really as as terrible an
employee as they make you out to be no
and they make you out to be like
somebody who's like starts to make an
airline reservation and kind of gets
through one one to half of it
i have done that and then
you cannot bet you know what you can get
back i'm going to say this i'm going to
say this in sona's defense you probably
don't want to go down this path because
and listen i say this with love i am
quite uh sona's got a book that's coming
out yeah it's called world's worst
assistant i do yeah she wrote that
that's really good and i wrote the
forward and um i'm i i'm quite honest in
the forward i believe yes uh
but um but one of the things i got out
of my way to say is that i really
we i love sona
we are besties
but um some of the [ __ ] she has pulled
oh yeah no i mean
you know what's interesting my wife has
pointed out to me that i
she's never seen me the minute sona had
these twins and i started getting
pictures
i stop everybody and make them look at
pictures of her kids and she said she
did mikey yeah she said you didn't do
this with our kids and you still don't
do it with our kids i'm like ah kids
look at these guys i mean i'm going to
say he's going to be the godfather to my
boys yeah
that's how yeah that's how we're very
close he's going to be he has he been
told this is this am i in on like the
best i know i'm
[Laughter]
no no um no they asked me uh i came over
and you and you and tech asked me to do
it and it was really funny because it
was very subtle but her husband tack
who's a very funny guy
he had music playing in the background
and then they said they wanted to talk
to me about something and then
he quietly i don't know for the remote
control or something but he switched the
song and it was just playing kind of
quietly in the background but he started
playing as he was asking me as they were
both asking me the godfather thief
and so he's talking and it's so it's you
come to me yeah it's but it's so it was
so subliminal it was at this kind of low
level and then i i heard like though
but it's subliminal and they're like we
want to ask you something and then they
it was really
it was really funny